he's part one he's what way giveth and
the visitor result down on the page that
I believe is to the end and there's some
segmentation right what are we adding up
the sub off okay from naught n or just n
ck right okay okay so this is these
things have both be given to us
so what mark clearly belongs to what
goes in between these lines so it's all
like to give me a suggestion okay I need
to say I need to say and let X equal 1
and then once you've done that you've
got 1 plus 1 to the end come on don't
skimp on that inside how many precious
seconds do you save to write 1 plus 1
instead of 2 okay this is given to you
the question so you can't get marks for
that
okay on the right hand side you're just
going to do the substitution that means
this all one there right it's a non
trivial one that means that there's a 1
squared here and all the way up there
are end ones on the last term okay then
from there I think you're okay for you
to get to this line right so this like
your point quit you've got part 1 part 2
how are we going to get through there to
something reasonable that doesn't
require me to punch into my calculator
and read more numbers
okay so when N equals a right
you can use this now I prefer I just
like kind of starting from this like
this is what they asked me to work
through and I can see that this is
really just this with a set value so I'm
gonna write that as from N equals zero
is beside the bottom and I go all the
way up to a hundred and the thing that
I'm adding up is a hundred chews and
I've said okay that's okay yeah doesn't
know it's just a dummy variable yep so
on the basis of this result that's just
and naturally as you can imagine you
don't need to evaluate that all right so
then you get to part three and it says
show that and then there's a result
there now have a look at the result
there's a clue particularly the
left-hand side that tells you what
technique what method a strategy you
could use to get from all this stuff to
that load what's the clue there's the
end and then there's the n minus 1 right
so what this really is is n X to the N
minus 1 and that's like kind of the
obvious indicator that you have to
differentiate both sides okay now have a
look right differentiate with respect to
X okay so this is not the line I want a
different shape do you see that even
though it's like oh wait look it's got
that to the anything right this is not
what I want to differentiate which is
lying should I differentiate the very
first one this guy up here okay we have
two different here both sides right I'm
going to start with just this first line
which is given to us in the question
what are we going to use on the left
hand side what I required
different chain with respect to X right
so that this is chain rule right this is
chain rule it's like well it's been so
long since I did the big round what I
had to use the different yet okay so
this is going to be and outside of X
okay so you can see aha
there there what this turns into that
once I make the same substitution I'm
gonna get this and two into the month
one that I need you okay what about on
the right hand side what's happening
okay so that's a constant so it's gone
in c1 times X that just becomes and
let's see what all right we're at the
next step okay so I'm just gonna put
that there right that's the x squared I
want to establish a pattern so even
though I don't have a what I've got
three terms over there but my third like
zero terms disappear so I'm gonna a key
NC 3 3 x squared class dot the dot
what's my last term
okay happy so now that I've got this
I've done all the stuff with the exes
now I can actually make the substitution
right so just like I did before a little
let X equal one and then the result that
you need pops out okay so it's gonna be
+ 2 n minus 1
they've already got the CC mutation
right all of these X terms are going to
collapse but look you've got maybe you
want to highlight this for yourself
right you've got this extra guy hanging
on you've got a 1 here then a 2 & 3 and
then a right so therefore what you've
got in your simulation has a couple of
differences from what we had over there
on that C notation right for starters
what's the first value front yeah good
book seat 1 2 3 as opposed to 0 1 2 okay
so this is from 1 up 2 so there's one
less tenant that's important by the way
and what's the general term hey and see
why yeah I suppose I wrote it with the
camera but they've provided twist in
this form so that's gonna confuse you
you happy one of them so you've got your
brain all limbered up and then you turn
over the page now as we talked about
before in an HSE question usually the
arm the A's and B's and C's have nothing
to do with each other usually the one
Susan threes were used to that but you
can see if you read this question now
just maybe take a minute to read it wrap
your head around it eventually once you
get to part 3 you'll notice it says
using poppy it references this and then
you get given an expression that looks
remarkably similar to the way I finished
here okay so clean this is going to be
related so what I want you to do for a
second because this is the most
important part think about this room
before I show you the answer this is
like okay it's a typical combinations
privet hedge depression what's
challenging about it is you don't know
anything about any of the quantities
everything's abstract there's n of these
are of these K whatever so this is a lot
harder to quantify okay so I'm gonna
give you a moment if you're struggling
being ahead yourself don't feel bad I
when it looked it up 4%
state 4% big step got part one you might
be that's pretty bad right 2% of the
state got part three okay so this was
not done well so by the time we're
finished with this lesson you'll be part
of that 2% but look at it see what you
can work out before I show you the
answer maybe you want to try and list
out a few options yourself